imagine a world of endless possibilities
a world where every decision you make
splits reality in half
and then the next decision
splits it into another half
and then again
and again
creating an infinite number of parallel
universes
how could this be possible
in what ways would your life be
different in other realities
and
how could these universes ever intersect
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the multiverse was real
thanks to the parallel worlds of the
marvel cinematic universe
you could already be familiar with the
idea of multiverses
many theories suggest our universe isn't
the only one
there could be many many more
possibly an infinite number
and these universes could all be very
different
some could mirror our reality
some could have intelligent
civilizations other than us
and many could have radically different
laws of physics
so
make sure you plant your feet firmly
you could be about to discover a
universe with no gravity at all
okay i'm sure you have a lot of
questions that makes sense you just
learned that our universe could be one
of billions
or more
but let's start with a question that
concerns the most important person here
you would you exist in any of these
other universes
well not to bring you down but according
to astrophysicist ethan siegel
the answer is likely no
in the formation of each universe there
are a mind-blowing number of
possibilities of how particles could
interact
for you to exist in multiple universes
the seven octillion atoms that make up
your body would need to come together in
the exact right combination
multiple times
it's like the ultimate version of the
infinite monkey theorem
that idea is that with an infinite
amount of time
a monkey randomly typing
could eventually write a replica of
shakespeare's hamlet
but that would be what it takes to make
one single replica of you
even if that did happen the chances that
anything else is the same in this
universe are very
very small
that'd be a lot of hamlets
you'd likely not have the same family
the same earth or the same solar system
but with the potential that an infinite
number of universes exist
theoretically there could be two or more
of you out there leading wildly
different lives
there could be a universe where another
outcome would be possible for every
decision you make
it wouldn't matter how big or small
in one world you turn on a light in
another you turn it off
so there could be a universe where you
took that job overseas
one where you stayed together with the
next partner and even one where you died
in that car crash
or even an infinite number of car
crashes
tragic i know but possible
also dinosaurs could still roam the
earth and be our supreme overlords
i'm just saying it's all possible
if these different universes exist
would you be able to visit them
could you ever contact the infinite
other versions of yourself
[Music]
well that depends on which type of
multiverse theory you'd subscribe to
according to one theory when the big
bang created our universe
it could have created a universe on the
opposite side of the timeline
it would be built out of identical
versions of every particle in our
universe
it could mirror life in every way
but even if there were other universes
you wouldn't be able to just travel to
the edge of our own and cross over to
the other side
that universe would be moving away from
ours at the speed of light
so
you'd need to be moving at the speed of
light too
so unless you could figure out how to
perceive and travel through higher
dimensions
there's a really
really small chance you'd be able to
meet your alternate self
but take solace in the possibility that
there could be a dream reality out there
somewhere and you could be living in it
well not you exactly but a version of
you living a version of your best life
then again who knows if any of these
theories are real
this could be our one universe with only
one earth and one you
hey might as well make the best of it
but then again
maybe one of these days another universe
could crash into ours
oh
well
that's a story for another
what if
[Music]